the new ceo of hertz says he will fix a
problem that cbs news revealed months
ago customers who say they were falsely
arrested after the cars they
legitimately rented were reported as
stolen our consumer investigative
correspondent anna warner has talked to
several of these hearst customers who
were wrongly accused anna good morning
good morning nate you know hertz has
been tight-lipped about these issues but
now just days after u.s senators started
putting on the pressure ceo steven
shurer says rectifying the situation is
a priority he promises to do right by
customers not treated fairly shure also
admitted for the first time that some
customers were wrongly accused of car
theft here's how he explains it
what played out here is we had cars that
were stolen or allegedly stolen we put a
police report in when that car was found
the report was rescinded and
unfortunately in certain circumstances
when that car went out again it wasn't
in fact rescinded and so the customer
was accused
sher says hertz has put new policies in
place to address these problems that's
news and also said he's confident the
company will reach a settlement with
customers who are suing hurts in
bankruptcy court now the attorney
representing those claimants francis
alexander malafi told us we shall see if
mr schur's words were simply lip service
to the street to shore up investor
confidence and deflect from congress
damning their conduct or if hertz
intends to make good on its promise
sher and hertz still say this is not a
systemic problem but keep in mind there
are still people actively being
prosecuted
who say that false police reports were
filed against them and you know you have
the ceo acknowledging that that did
happen in some places i think the kind
of the conversation now centers around
uh do right what does he mean by doing
right by those customers right and there
is no settlement yet right so the
question is
how will this get resolved when will it
get resolved for those customers and
what happens to the people who are
actively being prosecuted because in the
past hertz has said it's not our job to
pull back these police reports
so what does that mean for the people
who are still facing charges including
the guy who got off the cruise ship we
featured a month or so ago
who's still facing charges and other
people and you've given such vivid
examples too of people that have gotten
into trouble we see mr schurr on tv
wouldn't you like to talk to amanda i
would i've put in that request yeah i
have not heard back we'd very much like
to sit down with him get his perspective
talk to him about these issues and hear
what he has to say he's new to the job
right yeah yeah he's been there about a
month and
and you're friendly
and this is another example of
investigative reporting creating change
necessary change so thank you well done
thanks